this was a doctor's news conference to
answer to the president's medical
condition
it raised serious questions first on the
president's condition itself
very good see the doctors he's in
exceptionally good spirits and in fact
as we were completing our
multi-disciplinary rounds this morning
uh the quote he left us with was i feel
like i could walk out of here today and
that was a very encouraging
comment from the president but that
positive mood
wasn't necessarily reflected by the
white house an unnamed official said
the president's vitals over the last 24
hours were very concerning
and the next 48 hours will be critical
in terms of his care
we are still not on a clear path to a
full recovery
and then there's a timeline before his
helicopter transfer to hospital
donald trump had tweeted his diagnosis
in the early hours of friday morning
35 hours before that medical news
conference
the doctor complete with presidential
seal on his coat
put the timeline back to 72 hours
just 72 hours into the diagnosis now the
first week of covid and a particular day
7-10 are the most critical
in determining the likely course of this
illness and then there's the treatment
the president received
the doctors say that was administered 48
hours previously
that would take it back to thursday
morning long before the president had
tweeted his diagnosis
about 48 hours ago the president
received a special antibody therapy
directed against the coronavirus and
we're working very closely with the
company to monitor him
uh in terms of that outcome um
yesterday evening he received his first
dose of ivory rem deserver
and our plan is to continue a five-day
treatment course for rendez-severe
a diagnosis 72 hours before the medical
bulletin
would mean president trump was in full
and active campaigning mode
whilst covert positive this was him in
minnesota on wednesday evening
the next day he was at events in new
jersey
the white house has since given a
clarification
of what the doctors had to say it speaks
not of 72 hours since diagnosis but of
three days
not of 48 hours since treatment but of
two days
it presents a timing less precise than
that given by the medical
team and provides room for maneuver
within the timeline
what it doesn't provide is clarity on
diagnosis
treatment and on just how well is
president trump
following the white house statement the
president's doctor
then issued a statement of his own and
spoke not of ours
but of day two and day three in line
with the white house guidance
[Music]
the contact tracing effort around the
president reads like a who's who
of the washington establishment who's
positive
and who's not at least seven people who
attended his white house unveiling
of supreme court nominee amy coney
barrett have since tested positive
donald trump's absence from the campaign
trail forces a dramatic shift in
republican strategy
one that had a presidential performance
at public events
at its heart at a time when team trump
needs to win over voters
it's lost its vote winner though for
this president
at this time there's more to life than
politics
james matthews sky news washington